That is weird!
(laughs)
👏👏
T-Series has most likely passed me so it doesn't matter what I upload at this point, does it?
I mean, I might as well get this over with...
BOOK REVIEW!
do do do do
Smash like if you're excited!
Yeah let's get some hype in the chat, guys.
As always, I've been reading, I've been doing my homework,
Have you?
I've been reading a lot of great literature.
Book of Disquiet, amazing.
Loved it.
House of the Dead, yeah it- it was... yeah.
Lolita. Loved it.
I'm not gonna kiss it though.
(laughs)
The Count of Monte Cristo. Woah!
For some reason I thought I would see through myself,
that's the level of brainlet I am.
Incredible.
It recommended by Slazo, I-
mm
Definitely a kiss from Pewds
I also read, uh, these two books that we're gonna discuss today.
Oh god. Can't show that.
It's got tiddies on the front.
Now let's just jump into it, shall we?
I told you guys to read this book,
Did you do your homework?
I'm sorry I made you guys read this, and then
Six months later, here I am. Okay?
BUT YOU READ IT.
You had plenty of time to finish this. Come on.
Literally you can pause the video and finish it now.
Do it.
Lets review this together for the first time of Book Review.
So, little quickly about Kobo Abe,
he is described as the Franz Kafka of Japan.
Whatever that means, I'm told that he focuses on, uh, nightmarish type of scenario.
Which definitely fits into this novel.
I picked this book because it's very simple read and I know that you guys are simpletons
I'm just kidding.
I just wanted something that everyone could enjoy.
It's also sort of deceivingly straight forward in a sense that there's a hidden meaning in there.
You gotta read between the lines, bois.
First of all, lets go through the synopsis.
There's actually a film based on this movie. Which won, it says here on the back, it won the 1973 Cannes Film Festival.
And its an amazing film. I definitely recommend you guys should watch it.
So the story starts off with a man walking on the dunes.
"We don't really know anything about him,
However, the book itself starts off with, uh
telling us about a man who disappeared and no one saw
And after seven years, there was no trace of him
so, therefore, the police declare him as dead.
So we follow this man who walks in the dunes,
We don't really know anything about him, like I said,
Except that he likes to collect insects as a hobby.
And that's why he's on these, uh, faraway sand dunes to hopefully find rare species of insects.
He takes a nap, and, uh, when he wakes up
he finds out that he missed the last bus.
from- to return him to
wherever he lives
And therefore, he meets up with some of the locals who offers that he can stay with them overnight.
So the locals basically live in these houses that are located within the dunes.
So they are deep down between these giant walls of sand essentially.
So you'd have to climb down through a rope ladder to get down to one of the houses.
Now, at first everything seems fine, he meets up with a woman who lives there
and he's gonna stay just overnight with her.
However, we get told very quickly,
that, uh, something is off about this whole situation
Not just from her face
goddamn that's creepy
Next day, he finds out that the ladder is gone so he can't leave the place.
He tries to climb back, but it's basically impossible,
since the sand is so coarse and it just gets everywhere.
So, to prevent the house from getting crushed by the constant flow of sand, they have to shovel sand aside,
um, away from the house
And that's just a constant thing they have to do.
And the woman there for wants to stay with him to help him do this, uh, labor
that they are obligated to do to live in this very bizarre location
So, one way to describe this book it's... if you dont like sand I got bad news for ya."
"I love the comments of this."
"Yet again George Lucas steal from another film I can't believe it."
"George Lucas stole from us yet again."
"So this is the basic plot, he tries to do everything he can to escape from this situation..."
"He's also quite clever, which is nice for a change when people are stuck in these weird situations."
"He also even managed to escape at one point but uh he gets caught because it's just too far off this place."
"And he gets taken back to the house again."
"At the end of the novel, he had even discovered a way to exert water from the sand."
"So he could get drinking water much more easily."
"Which is obviously a big discovery for him, but that doesn't really help him escape from the place either."
"And the last page basically reads..."
"Spoilers!"
"There was no particular need to hurry about escaping. On the two way ticket he held in his hand now the destination and time of departure were blanks for him to fill in as he wished."
"In addition, he realized that he was bursting with the desire to talk to someone about the water trap. And if he wanted to talk about it, there wouldn't be better listeners than the villagers."
"He would end by telling someone: if not today, then tomorrow."
"He might as well put off his escape until sometime after that."
"And he was therefore declared a missing person."
"So Kubo Abe himself lived very poor at some point in his life I don't know when."
"but he lived with his wife and he basically sustained himself from selling vegetables and charcoal."
"I think he must have drawn from that personal experience into this story."
"Very similarly, in this novel, the main character still has the bare minimum to get by."
"He still gets food, he still gets cigarettes, he still ocassionally gets Sake and if he saves up money, the people in the village, he can trade stuff with."
"These all essentials is also at the cost of his freedom of course and by the end of the novel we know that he's already made his choice and he chose to stay which means..."
"he doesn't just loose his freedom but he also essentially disappears."
"Just like in the begining of the novel which happens to another person"
"Now, the sand in this novel is what imprisons the main character."
"Its what keeps him trapped and forced to do this physical labor to stay alive."
"And just like time, the sand is constantly flowing, it's something he can't escape from."
"If he doesn't stop, it will literally crush him."
"I guess he begs the question, What's the difference of being trapped time and being trapped by the sand like this character."
"Even if you escape, are you ever even truly free?"
"Aren't we all trapped in one way or another?"
"But I really think that is probably what I mean I dont know you can always interpret it as many ways but."
"It's like he discovered this trap in the end to get water more easily."
"And its a way for him to distract himself."
"from these idea of escape."